let's imagine you're a corn farmer and
you would dream of having nice healthy
corn crop like we see in this picture
but being a farmer isn't as simple as
planting the seeds and making sure that
the crop gets enough sunshine and water
and fertilizer
you also have to deal with pests and
pests you can view as anything that
might eat your crop or destroy your crop
or make it just really hard for you to
have a good crop
now some of you all are familiar with
the notion of pesticides where you're
essentially poisoning the pests now for
various reasons that might not be a good
idea and we'll talk more about it and so
there's a notion of integrated pest
management which is how we can do
multiple things which might include
pesticides or might not include
pesticides to really keep things under
control
and to get a good sense of how bad a
pest can be i will introduce you to the
western corn root worm
now the reason why it's called a worm
even though it's adult face it does not
look like a worm is that in its larval
phase when it's a baby it looks like a
worm and even though the adult will also
feed on the corn silks the real damage
is done in the larval stage when they're
feeding on the roots that's why they're
called corn root worms and the usda
estimates that just in the united states
damage due to western corn rootworm is
about 1
billion dollars per year
about 800 million of that is just lost
corn crop and about 200 million of that
is all the cost in order to prevent this
pest from doing their damage
now as i mentioned if we're thinking
about integrated pest management there's
many ways of addressing this
one way of course that many people think
of is pesticides and this is an image of
crop dusting i don't think this is a
cornfield here but you can see the
pesticides coming from the biplane it's
a way of spreading the pesticides not
the only way but for various reasons
this is not optimal you could view it as
polluting the environment in certain
ways a lot of us aren't so keen on
eating crops that have pesticides on
them and we've learned in other videos
on evolution and natural selection
there's variation in any population and
the more that you expose a population to
something and it kills off the ones that
are susceptible the more chances that
the ones that aren't as susceptible
reproduce and thrive so at some point
you might have an insecticide resistant
pest on your hands and then your
insecticide isn't going to be all that
useful
so when we think about integrated pest
management we think about all right what
are other ways to address this maybe in
conjunction maybe ways that could be
perceived to be more natural
well one obvious thing is to think about
well what are the predators of that pest
and this is the wasp spider and this is
what's known as a ladybug in the in
north america and a lady bird in much of
the rest of the world and they will
actually feed on the western corn
rootworm so you might want to introduce
this onto your farm if you're trying to
grow that corn
another thing that farmers have done to
some degree of success is early planting
by planting the crop early it's less
favorable for the root worm to lay their
eggs and also it gives a chance for the
roots to get stronger so that by the
time that they're attacked by
the root worm they're going to be more
resilient
you could also have hybrid versions of
corn that just have larger roots so once
again they're going to be more resilient
to the rootworm
another technique is to genetically
modify the corn and that also is a bit
of a controversial topic depending on
who you talk to you might have heard
things about gmo genetically modified
organism some people think they're fine
some people are wary of them but there
is a transgenic version of corn
transgenic means that we took dna from
some other organism and put it into the
corn and that transgenic version is
known as bt corn that actually has dna
from a bacteria which produces a protein
which is harmful to certain types of
root worms now another really
interesting technique which people have
used to some degree of success is known
as crop rotation let's imagine we're
looking down from the sky onto a corn
crop here so we're looking down from
above so what normally happens is is
that the eggs are laid near the corn and
the larvae can't travel so far so they
if they're near the corn they get to the
roots and then they're able to the
reproduction cycle goes on but if we
rotate the crops so that the next year
we're not planting corn here but maybe
we are planting the corn
over here and then in that first place
we're planting soybean well that can
solve the problem because the eggs will
be laid here but next year the corn is
going to be here
and over here we will have the soybean
which is not a suitable food for the
corn rootworm
now what's really interesting this is
another one of those fascinating stories
of evolution and natural selection are
there cases because there's variation in
populations where some of the adult root
worm actually doesn't lay their eggs in
the same corn crop where they feed they
lay it in an adjacent corn crop so that
next year when the crop rotation happens
then their larvae are going to have
access to the corn in the other field
now you might say how did they know that
how did they know that the farmers were
planning to rotate well generally the
rotations are pretty simple you keep
alternating between two crops like corn
and soybean and most of the western corn
rootworm would not have done that but
just some of them might have started to
randomly travel a little bit further and
then those would be more likely to
reproduce so the ones that are more
likely to reproduce will then exist more
and then that behavior would be passed
on if it is a genetic trait
there's other situations once again
because of variation in populations
where some of the eggs stay dormant for
an extra year so even though you might
rotate to corn this year the year after
that you rotate back to corn and then
the eggs hatch and the larva could feed
so it's a fascinating almost arms race
between the farmer and these pests but i
hope you appreciate it's far more
interesting than you might have realized
before and i haven't even given you a
comprehensive list of all the types of
pests and all of the ways that you might
want to manage it you can do physical
removal you can do barriers maybe you'll
think of another creative way to have
integrated pest management